hello everyone and welcome to today's
webinar cell and gene therapy solutions
enabling PSC translation workflows I'm
Alexis Krause of laberd's and I'll be
your moderator for today's event
today's educational web seminar is
presented by lapper
and brought to you by thermo Fisher
Scientific to learn more about our
sponsor please visit www.cminds.com
locks and click send we'll answer as
many questions as we have time for at
the end of the presentation if you have
trouble seeing or hearing the
presentation click on the support tab
found at the top right of the
presentation window or report your
problem by clicking on the ask a
question box located on the far left
your screen this presentation is
educational and thus offers continuing
education credits please click on the
continuing education credits tab located
at the top right of the presentation
window and follow the process to obtain
your credits
I now present today's speaker dr. Tiye
hexam field application scientists cell
therapy Thermo Fisher Scientific dr.
hexam has a doctorate in cell and
molecular biology from Tulane University
studied chronics variable stress and its
effects on dendritic morphology and
synaptic plasticity from there she did
an NIH fellowship at UCSD looking at
Alzheimer's disease and stress hormone
signaling in human hippocampus and human
NSCs neural stem cells derived from IPS
CS she spent the last five years working
in cell therapy with regard to primary
cells 510k medical devices and cell
separation technologies for a complete
biography on our speaker please visit
the biography tab at the top of your
screen
dr. hexa you may now begin your
presentation
thanks so much for that intro Alexis I
really appreciate it thanks everyone for
joining us on the webinar today I'd like
to talk to you about enabling your PSP
translational workflows what does it
take for you to take those PSC and
cultures that you're working with and
and take them to clinic so the IDs C
Fields has come a long way in the last
20 years as you know it's been a 20-year
anniversary of when the PIA stem cells
started and I pscs have come in more
recent years and it's come a long way so
as you can see on this slide there's a
multitude of clinical studies being
conducted now utilizing this exciting
technologies however I want to talk to
you about what some of the pain points
and pitfalls are that you should be
aware of when you're moving towards this
goal
so today I'll talk to you about an
introduction into the cell and cell
therapy and translational workflows that
we have how you can generate and expand
itsc how you should how we recommend
quality testing of your IPS see Bank and
as well as some of the safety tests that
you should be performing that we
recommend performing when when you're
going to the clinic
so as you as you know the Fallon
gene-therapy industry has a number of
challenges that we're facing
there's management of supply chain and
logistics how you can reproducibly
perform your safety and control enabling
commercial use right
I haven't redundancy and your
manufacturing and making sure that your
raw materials are cGMP grade there's
clinical trial risk management file
processing how can you make sure that
what you're doing in the lab at the
bench now is something that can be
scaled up and scaled out for clinical
trials making sure that you can Medusa
nuff let alone for when it's commercial
if it goes that way
regulatory also has a number of
compliance documentation and support
issues that need to be evaluated and
complied with and you want to make sure
that you have consistency in your
quality and performance of the therapy
that you're trying to produce so when I
talk to people about this I like to talk
about starting with the end in mind
there was a an article that came out
recently that evaluated a large number
of clinical trials is somewhere in the
range of I think 836 and when they were
evaluating the clinical trials they
evaluated what would happen if you
change one raw material in the middle of
the clinical trials what what does that
do how does that impact how does impact
cost how does it impact efficiency and
what they found evaluating the clinical
trials is that the median cost if you if
you change one critical raw material and
in the clinical trial you can impact the
cost as much as 150 thousand dollars in
Phase one and up to half a million
dollars in Phase two so making sure that
you that you're thinking about what
you're going to be doing early on and
making sure that you're utilizing the
materials that help with all of these
industry challenges is really important
it can it can sometimes make or break
what what the clinical trial is going to
be doing and so I we want to be a
resource for you in that and help you
think about these things early on so
that we can help enable you to develop
the therapies that I'm rooting for all
of you guys to be developing so
with that let's talk about some of the
things that we can help you with at
thermo Fisher with that so why am i a
scientist from thermo Fisher here
talking to you about this translational
workflow this because at thermo Fisher
we believe in making the world safer
cleaner and healthier and when it comes
to cell and gene therapy we're committed
to helping you do that through our value
proposition the world really needs your
guys's brilliant minds to get us to the
next treatment and we want to be the
partner to help you get there so I'd
like to talk about the PSD workflow that
we've been developing with our partners
and talk to you how you can be thinking
about that ends at the beginning middle
or end wherever you may be in this
workflow so some of the ways that we can
help enable you is with cGMP grade
products giving you confidence in our
results helping you with that
scalability that I talked to you about
on the last one and really by becoming a
trusted partner for you so a lot of
times when I'm out talking to through
the scientists that we partner with it's
really just about making sure that we're
all growing in this quickly changing
field together and so that's something
that I get really excited about in my
and my job that I get to do I get to
talk to you guys about these things
additionally we have a very broad
portfolio that we can support you with
let's thermo Fisher
so let's talk about that PSC workflow so
here's an example of an integrated
approach for how you might be generating
your IPSC cell banks so the first things
that you do is usually have a donor and
you take some sort of somatic cell from
them and you'll be reprogramming them
into IPSC so once they're reprogrammed
we we generally talk about doing quality
testing of the ICS DS so that you can
save yourself a lot of time and energy
and effort from what you're doing
downstream so I get a lot of questions
when I'm in the field about Tia this one
didn't reprogram or it's differentiating
spontaneously or there's different stuff
going on and a lot of the times you can
alleviate a lot of the pain points that
that are involved with pluripotent stem
cells if you do this quality testing
early on and upfront after you do the
quality testing of your ear banks you
might have the release of those and you
freeze them down or you go into the
differentiation of yourself into what
your final products therapy product
might be following the differentiation
of the cells you'll want to do QC of the
final formulation and safety testing and
from there you have your self cell
therapy products that will go back into
the patient
so I'd like to talk to you about some of
the tools that we've developed to help
you with each stage of this this
workflow
talk about the generation and expansion
of IPs see
so one thing that's really important
when you're doing the transition from
what you're working on in the labs and
the bench to your clinical work is to
make sure that you have translatable
products so we have something called the
site attune ICS 2.0 sendai reprogramming
kit and this is really useful for doing
your ru o we utilize the Sun dye virus
because it's transient and you can get
it out of the cell
after you're done reprogramming it
something that you can eliminate and it
doesn't integrate in addition we have
the CTS version which will help you take
that to the clinic and what's really
exciting about this technology is that
it's the first off-the-shelf
reprogramming system designed for
clinical and translational research so I
believe I'll talk to about what is what
that what it means to be CTS and the
slide deck and if not it's something I'd
like to really talk about at the end so
let's talk about reprogramming
so the site attune ICS to point once and
then route programming tip is designed
for the translational use so what are
some of the ways that we take took that
REO product the 2.0 and made it into 2.1
what did we change to make it safer to
go to clinic so first of all we did this
because we had we had some investigators
that we were working with that were
having a lot of great results with the
2.0 and they wanted to go to clinic and
so you know in our partnership with them
it was like what do we need to make this
safe and help you take it to clinic and
so that's how the development of this
product came along so that's one of the
things that we did is we've replaced the
see Mike with the L mix and the L make
is shown to have a weaker
transformational activity so that's
giving it a little more safety
additionally we remove the VSA because
there's if you have animal components
such as VSA there's a risk of viruses
that we can't test for and so you
eliminate some of the risks associated
with the animal product additionally the
viral vectors are produced in a GMP
certified facility making sure that you
have consistency of your material so
we're really proud of the fact that this
is something that you can take from the
reo to the CTS version for a seamless
transition to the clinic so that you can
you can be developing your process and
not and the research is only space and
then when you're ready to do these
clinical studies or preclinical
workflows that you can transition over
to the CTS product and and know that
it's going to be a consistent in the
same way
so let's talk about the development of
the Zeno free media that that is used
with this reprogramming kit so as you
can see on the very left hand side
there's a number of colored spheres
bumps on the graphics sound so
scientific doesn't it okay so as you can
see the blue one is the control fps and
so you can see the percentage of GFP
transduction that was achieved with this
is 92% and when we were evaluating
different Zeno free media we wanted to
make sure that we could have similar
performance there's always some sort of
trade-off when you when you have animal
products when you get rid of them
because we know that the cells like
animal products so it's just they live
in an animal they like animal products
however when you're trying to get to
that safety that's best for the patient
you're going to have some sort of
trade-off in the performance but we
really want to design our products to be
the best performing when it comes to
those you know free criteria for safety
so as you can see there were there were
three media that that were okay and two
that were really good performance that
had similar transduction efficiencies so
then after we evaluated the transduction
efficiency in the media we looked at how
the fibroblast growth rate performed and
as you can see in the middle graph there
there's a number of days in culture
where the fibroblast growth rate is good
it's all really comparable for
candidates five and six
after that we wanted to make sure that
the reprogramming efficiency was
comparable so as you can see on the
right hand graph you have the SPS in
blue candidate five in candidate six for
the media conditions and candidate five
giving a better route programming
efficiency like I said there's always a
little bit of trade off when you go
animal-free but of those five different
zero freeze fibroblasts media
formulations that we initially tested
for we were able to pick top the top two
based on these growth rates and
reprogramming efficiency
so in addition to that we want to talk
about how that is you know free media
supports the isolation and expansion of
the primary fiberglass so a lot of you
some of you are doing it with skin I'm
talking to more and more people doing it
from blood we also will be talking about
that in later in the slide deck but you
know generally you take a skin punch
biopsy from a from a patient or a donor
and you have the six oil coated plate
with collagen we had two to three pieces
in 1 millimolar each well for well and
we cultured those for 10 to 14 days in
the Zeno free media so after the
culturing what we wanted to do was see
what was the reprogramming efficiency
and were they normal cheerio typically
so the Zeno free candidate media 5 was
successful to derive fibroblasts from
the human skin and the resulting
fibroblasts are found to be karo
typically normal you can see the G
banding here on the bottom right right
corner showing that it's a normal result
so that's really great that speaks
really well to the product that that
safety so just to remind you where where
we are in the workflow so we've just
discussed the reprogramming going into
itsc so let's talk more about what some
of the supporting materials are that you
can utilize when you're doing the Zeno
free reprogramming so if you're using a
zeal free reprogramming you want to make
sure that you're doing it in a Zeno free
entire workflow it doesn't really matter
if you eliminate one if you don't
eliminate it down the line so we have an
entire Zeno free workflow for you that
helps support path so the give Co so we
had the fiber bus that were reprogrammed
with the CTS 2.1 kit using Zeno free
conditions and at day seven they were
harvested with our CTS Triple E so this
select enzyme is one of our CTS products
and it helps you to disassociate the
cells and replace them so then we
replayed at them on laminin 5 to 1 and
we have CGS products for this as well
the following day the media was
change to either essentially or cts
essentially media and the sequential
media changes were carried out until day
18 now after 18 days we evaluated the
transduction reprogramming efficiency
and measured it with alkaline
phosphatase so as you can see in this
sis data and graph here the essential 8
medium which is our researchers only
product is really compatible in giving
great results compared to the CTS v8
medium so the cts e8 medium which is
what we recommend for your translational
workflow performs just as good if not
better as the essential 8 so there's
another form of us helping you go from
research youths only to the CTS cell
therapy grade product that will help you
with that translational workflow so you
can feel confident in the results you're
driving at the bench now making sure
that you get it to where it needs to be
and is translatable down the line
so what about what if I want to do
something besides fiber blastia you know
so I'm getting there are articles that
say that cyber blasts since their skin
cell they're exposed to Sun they're
exposed to more mutations potential and
so we have investigators who are
utilizing other cell types and what's
really exciting about this reprogramming
kit is that it supports reprogramming of
other cell types too and so in addition
to doing the fibroblast reprogramming
the scientists in our lab also did
reprogramming with cd34 positive cells
with hematopoietic stem cells and with
t-cells and so as you can see here with
the 2.1 and the 2.0 kit you you have
good reprogramming efficiency as that
works among all of the cell types
there's always that little little
trade-off when you're doing the
translational work to go to the safer
version but I'm really quite happy with
with the ability to show that you can
you can utilize this in a lot of cell
types and it's exciting
so in addition to that we wanted to
evaluate if you're going to do this the
t-cell reprogramming we know that you
have to have antibody or anti cd3 coated
plates or we wanted to make sure that
you could utilize our entire workflow so
we have CTS cd3 cd28 which are known to
be used in commercial cell therapy
products and we wanted to make sure that
that worked seamlessly in the workflow
as well so we compared using those cd3
cd28 beads with the traditional version
of having the cd3 antibody coding
sometimes the antibodies aren't so cell
and gene therapy grade material so for
your regulatory reasons you want to try
and maintain using products that are
that are easier for you when you're
filing the IND when you're trying to
transition to the clinical workflow and
so as you can see in this left hand
graph the cd3 cd28 beads performed just
as well as the consistent as the
classical 83 antibody coding we also
wanted to arm you with the information
about utilizing different matrices for
growing yourself so we have a
recombinant laminin five-to-one and we
also have the tree nekton as part of our
cell therapy system products that we can
offer you when you're translating to the
clinic to file your high-end D and as
you can see the laminate five to one has
a slightly better reprogramming
efficiency than vit Renekton but I but
they both work very well and depending
on your setup what you're doing down the
line and how your cells are and the
investigators some of my investigators
most of it Renekton more than the
recombinant v t-1 but regardless you
have the options when you're utilizing
the CTS products from from thermo Fisher
Scientific
another question that I get a lot when
I'm when I'm working with customers I
mean with scientists in the field is do
you have like how can you support me
with the entires you know free workflow
and so one thing that I really love is
the scientists and Ardie have prepared
prepared protocols for you to help you
with the entirely compliant vino free
work flow so we can provide that to you
and in in a follow-up if you'd like and
we have the fibroblasts with cd34 and
the t-cells so and we want you to know
that we have this available for you so
that you don't have to go on
troubleshoot and develop this on your
own and something that we can we can
help support you with so depending on if
you're using t-cells and we have a
different media we recommend such as the
optimizer we also have CTS grade
cytokines that we can help perform
provide you with yeah and then we even
provide recipes for the fibroblasts
medium if you're utilizing fibroblasts
and that's provided in the CTF hydrogen
kit
so I'm talking to you about safety a lot
in this webinar but you know if you're
using something like a virus I'm telling
you free you should go without a virus
or without animal products because they
could have a viral viral risk however
I'm utilizing a virus to reprogram so
how can we make sure that there's
clearance of that that viral the sendai
virus so one thing that we're able to do
which is really nice is we can show you
that there is clearance of the sendai
virus so I told you as a transient virus
and so then don't just believe me prove
it right so here's the data to prove it
the rate of the sendai virus solution
was typically between five to eight
passages and then this is from our
fibroblast donors that were following
throughout this entire workflow so of
all of the clones
there was the sendai virus was
undetectable by passage eight so that's
that's really great to see that you know
it only takes eight passages before the
sendai virus has clearance complete
clearance from yourself however a lot of
times customers will come to us asking
how can i prove this to my regulatory
body so if you would like further
further confirmation that the send a
virus is cleared from your from your
your cultures we provide a custom TaqMan
send I quantification essay and this can
be used to further determine the exact
confit umber of sendai virus and its
backbone and monitor its dilution
throughout each passage so as you can
see we have the Sendai virus reference
material on the left we provide to you
the PC PCR kit and then you do the
amplification to show how its how its
programming out and in the bottom left
hand corner we showed PBMCs that we
reprogrammed and how how fast they
dilute out as well as the positive
control so this is a really nice
additional additional supporting product
that can help you show that you're
reprogramming worked
also you've gotten rid of the virus that
you used to reprogram
sorry excuse me it's not that it worked
it's just that you got rid of the virus
so you'll we'll show you how to test how
it works in these following slides so
wants different programs of cells how
can you do the quality testing of the
resulting ICSD Bank
so I've been showing you the workflow
where isolate reprograms Bank and
recover and now we're at this place
where we do expansion and gene editing
but before you do that you want to make
sure before you sum the copious amount
of time that we all know it can take
when you're working with plcs you want
to make sure that you're not going to
waste months differentiating testing
developing cells that might not be
appropriate so this is the number one
number one way that I see as a potential
for how you can save time money and and
headache so let's talk about the ways
that you can confirm to a potency and
make sure that you have the ability to
differentiate as well as karyotyping
so traditionally in the PSC space you
have qualitative antibody methods that
we utilize to show that they're
undifferentiated and that they can be
differentiated however I get I got a lot
of scientists telling me it takes a long
time it's painful I also have some
people that don't really trust the
antibody because you know sometimes
autofluorescence stuff like this so
there's a lot of need for making sure
that there's an actual quantitative way
to show that that you have the potential
to site a their undifferentiated
pscs and B that they have the ability to
differentiate in addition to this
there's no reference standards so this
makes it really difficult to compare
between lots of antibodies or what have
you as well as between labs so another
thing that's really important as you
have to progress in this translational
path you want to make sure sometimes you
might be having your manufacturing
facilities have multiple sites so you
might be you know manufacturing in the
US and you might be manufacturing in
Germany and you might be manufacturing
in Japan so you want to have the ability
to consistently compare between labs and
manufacturing sites to make sure that
you have consistent reprogramming and
differentiation so let's talk about how
we can help you with that
so the latest comprehensive methods they
are standardized able and scalable so we
have three three tests that we recommend
for your quality tests of your PSC so
the pleura test is a high density gene
expression assay that assesses put a
potency and the presence of stem cell
markers so this one is a really nice
because you can well I'll talk about it
in some of the following slides but it's
nice because you can compare and it has
a lot of reference material so that
there's a lot of ability to compare and
standardized between all the people who
are running this test the scorecard is a
high density gene expression array run
on a chip
we have scorecard gene expression F a
lower density TaqMan assay in addition
to evaluating self renewal you're also
evaluating the differentiation potential
and then finally for genomic stability
we have digital karyotyping and
genotyping in a single FA and we provide
that in two different forms we have
stereo stat and curio stat HD let's talk
about those a little bit more in depth
so the pleura test tool is a
computational model of pluripotency
based on transcriptome analysis we this
was developed by Hans Franz Josef Muller
and gene chance gene Loring at Scripps
and so this is an example I was also
talking to you about partnering with
with our with our with our partners so
this is a great example of partnership
and how we want to be partnering with
you as you develop ways to help advance
this field we want to help make that
available to to everyone so this is a
very widely published and comprehensive
reference set that you can benchmark
your samples to so you don't need
bioinformatics which makes it very user
friendly and the pleura test software
performs the analysis for you so if you
if you want to see more about this
there's always there's a number of
excuse me so the reference set has 450
samples 264 of them are human embryonic
stem cells
i PSC lines it's well published method
as I said but we also have a link on our
website where you can see the most
up-to-date publications that are
utilizing this so what's really great
about it is the more the more people
that use it the more the more comparison
we have about what's going on in the
field
get what the analysis data might look
like when you're when you're running the
pluripotency test so as you remember at
the beginning of the talk we did the
fibroblast reprogramming and we derived
three clones from the parental
fibroblasts
so that parental fibreglass is in the
bottom right hand corner in blue
that shows a high novelty score as well
as a very low pluripotency score so as
you can see the plur potency is on the
left-hand side and the novelty is on the
bottom and our ICSD clothes that we
reprogram and derived are high on the
pluripotency score and low in the
novelty score so what this means is that
they have high Flair potency and low
novelty which means they're they're not
being differentiated and they're not
differentiated so just this is a really
nice way to show that your clones are
flirting
so what are some other ways that we can
help with making sure that you have the
differentiation potential so I get a lot
of questions around this it's something
that's painful so if you're not doing
these quality tests upfront to show that
you have the reprogramming and it's done
in a proper way sometimes we just start
differentiating right away
oh look I got this stem-cell it looks
nice the morphology is beautiful but
then when we go to to work with the
cells and differentiate them sometimes
there's problems like oh well this one
only goes to hindbrain and this one goes
to this one so I you know there's a lot
of discussion about this when I'm
talking to scientists been working with
scientists on this and one of the ways
that you can help make sure that you're
setting yourself up for success is to
make sure that the stem cells that
you're utilizing out front have the
ability to differentiate into all three
germ layers so the scorecard panel is
attackman hpf human pluripotency panel
to evaluate that differentiation
potential so this was developed with as
Alex Meissner of Harvard and it's
composed of 93 genes with a cloud based
software
it's a published method that has good
adoption and we have generated it using
our CTS workflow once we generated the
clone the clones and the CTS workflow
the score chart assay we analyzed the
clones so I'm going to show you that on
the next page but here you can see the
publication and the specific genes by
category as well as the reference set
for what it was compared against
so the scorecard confirms tri lineage
differentiation potential and and let's
look at what that data looks like when
it when when you get it from the from
the scorecard itself so you have the
undifferentiated cells here and then
that's what we're measuring so the three
clones that we've been tracking
throughout this this talk have been
measured with the scorecard now the
green bar is a bar that shows two
self-renewal markers and then the box
plots these are reference sets of
undifferentiated cells so the
self-renewal in green shows that it has
high self-renewal markers and then the
blue orange and dark blue are the three
different germ layers so you have the
mesoderm endoderm and ectoderm and it's
showing that it's negative for those at
this time because these are
undifferentiated cells however as you
differentiate and you can show the that
they're able to differentiate into three
germ layers so as you differentiate that
green box will go down and the tri
lineage differentiation potentials of
these clones will go the opposite way
so that's a really helpful tool for for
helping assess that you have the
differentiation potential that you need
so that you don't waste countless days
weeks months trying to differentiate if
this excels that you were starting with
don't have the ability to differentiate
but you know don't just take my word for
it we this is been oh this is the how
the number of publications that have
utilized these tools and it's something
that's really exciting to see so a
recent stem cells report was talking
about unique excuse me utilizing the
scorecard employer test tool
in this in this paper they utilize that
they assess the pluripotency at a
functional level and distinguish normal
HP SCS from cells with a differentiation
defect so that's how they utilize score
cards for the pleura test they commented
that there's a lack of standardization
and clear potency assessment because
markers are demonstrated at mRNA or
protein levels and methods vary between
qualitative immunofluorescence staining
or quantitative facts and qPCR so in
this respect player test is a
significant advance because it advances
the global gene expression of a query
sample and provides the quantitative
results so these authors third third
party on guy staffers proposed that
plura test in combination with the HP SC
score card is a good way for routine
characterization of human floating stem
cells and like I mentioned when we were
talking earlier I you know I really
appreciate something that's standardized
where I can compare between labs or you
know that the colleagues that you're you
can even do it you can compare against
your competitors who you're competing
against for the next article right but
you want to make sure that you have that
standardization in the field and these
are tools that are really really great
to make sure that you can you have that
that reference set and that we're all
evaluating in the same way to help
advance the field instead of all of this
the typical talk that we have with well
you know if you do something if you hop
on your left foot and rub your nose just
right the stem cells will grow so
there's a you know to eliminate some of
that superstition or experience base and
try to make it more standardized so that
we can have consistent cell therapy
products as we advance the the PSC field
towards being able to produce salt
therapy cell therapy treatments so let's
let's remind ourselves where we are in
the workflow so we've just discussed two
of the quality testing for IPSC banks so
we talked about the pleura test and
attack man I'd like to talk to you next
about genomic stability in your PSC
cultures and why that's important
and then after that we'll talk about
some of the safety measures that we have
to evaluate when we're going to the
clinic and putting these back in the
patient so there's a there's a big
importance in assessing the genomic
stability of pluripotency m cells so
based on the literature about 20% of
PSCs are known to accumulate chromosomal
abnormalities in particular chromosomal
games there's other variants such as sub
chromosomal CNVs and SMBs that are less
prevalent in IPS use but as you can see
there's a couple of papers referenced
here and you know the most common
chromosomal aberrations are our gains or
deletion so the frequency of aberrations
in human es CS is 32 to 34 percent and
20 percent in the induced pluripotent
stem cells and so this really speaks to
the fact that there's there's a really
large need to make sure that you have
genomic stability that the reprogramming
didn't produce some sort of aberration
that that's dangerous a that's not going
to get you the results you need and
that's dangerous for the patient our our
potential treatment model that you're
working with
so we have two two ways to help you with
this we have to carry with that in the
karaoke at HD assays so this is a test
that is based on a large number of
probes so we have a in silico reference
based on 300 normal individuals in cell
line and then we've designed a number of
probes for these assays so the curio
staff has around three hundred and
fifteen thousand probes while the kurios
at HD has 2.6 million probes in there a
say this is sensitive for detection of
mosaicism and it's independent of
confirmation of copy state number which
helps you to get an accurate breakpoint
determination so as you can see in the
bottom left we recommend the curio stat
for research use and then we recommend
the curio stat HD for when you're going
to your translational workflow because
it gives you a really a much higher
resolution and as you can see there is a
ability to detect gains if you use the
hd25 250 KB so you have really nice
resolution here they are able to detect
SNP snips and it has a broad coverage
and high resolution so this is a really
nice tool for evaluating the genomic
stability so one thing that I get a lot
of questions about in the field is what
can carry off that do or not do because
the traditional way that people have
been evaluating this in their
pluripotent stem cells is G banding but
we know there's a number of pain points
with that associated with that so
sometimes there's a large backlog of
saito geneticists able to process it you
have to keep yourself alive when you're
shipping it whereas with our Theriot set
you can spin them down into a pellet and
ship them to us however let's be clear
about the difference in doing a G
banding versus a molecular based probe
so karaoke
versus gee branding we can definitely do
see Envy gain or loss we have the
increased ability to show SNP changes
which G branding doesn't have the
resolution to do we can both do an
applauding the cheerio set can also do
CN LOH and LOH changes as well as
mosaicism so since it's a molecular
based assay one thing that I want to
make sure that you're aware of is that
it can't show it'll show if the genes
are present but it can't show if the
genes have moved so any of the the
features that you might look for where
you have movement of a gene from one
chromosome to another such as inversion
translocations or snv will not be able
to be detected with this however
sometimes with G banding you know you
might not have the resolution to show
that either it just depends what another
thing that's important to consider that
if you do have a translocation which you
would be able to detect with the G
banding there's usually a large number
of deletions or there's usually
deletions that go along with that and
you won't be able to detect those
specific gene deletions unless you use a
molecular based assay like curiosa so
it's really good to - it's to utilize
this molecular based assay in addition
to some of the methods that have been
used previously which is - banding so at
the beginning of this talk we started
talking about reprogramming and
following our cell lines throughout this
this workflow excuse me
and so I want to show you that the
Carrio sat at what it looks like when
you do the readout of the molecular
based assay and then I want to show you
the clones that we derived with our
reprogramming kit and all of our Zeno
free workflows and what they look like
so one thing that's really great so
sometimes molecular based assays I don't
know about the audience but for me I
found them sometimes to be painful
depending on how the data comes to you
and so one thing that I really love
about how they've developed the software
for the scariest ethics is they show you
the molecular information and a format
that you're used to seeing in the past
so as you can see on the left you have
the carry off that assay and on the
right you have the G banding and so you
can see that they've designed the
software tool to show you the
information and a visually friendly
format and so it's really exciting so on
the top we have the normal h9 VSD normal
female and that's compared to the G
banding and then to show you that we can
detect the abnormal we also have the
abnormal male below and so as you can
see when there's extra chromosomes on
the G banding on the right it'll show up
as two bars on our software
excuse me so let's look at some of the
reprogramming that we did for this this
workflow so the ICSD clone that we
utilized with our our entire workflow
and reprogramming kit come out to be
normal so we have the parental
fibroblasts on the top left and then we
have the normal clones that came from
that same same parental fiberglass so as
you can see on the right when you line
up they're color coded now when you line
it up that they're all normal due to the
absence of blue or red triangle so if
you do have an abnormality there will be
a red or a blue triangle that'll draw
your eye to it and then you'll click
here I'll show you what it looks like in
the next slide
so what does it look like if you have an
abnormality so further analysis of the
pscs
we so we did a further analysis by
should I just showed you the Carrio stat
research use with a 315,000 probe now I
want to show you the Carrio stat HD
which is something that we recommend you
consider and utilize for your
translational use so at the top we have
the Carrio stat which shows no
chromosomal abnormalities at the lower
resolution which is about 2 MB gain gain
or loss so then if you look at the
carest at HD you see there's a little
red triangle it may or may not be hard
for you to see but we've circled it in
red and when what's really cool about
this software is it shows you visually
like oh here's something you need to
look at and then you'll click at it and
at the bottom of the screen there'll be
something that opens up and it'll show
you exactly what what is missing or
gained at that that site
so although detected there was a loss of
at the short arm of chromosome 7 it
didn't contain any genes and so that
shows that it's still safe to proceed
forward so that you've done the high
resolution you have a loss here in the
high resolution but there is no genes
that you actually lost so that gives you
great reassurance when you're when
you're thinking about steak
these these cells and putting them back
into a patient for the treatment we so
I've talked to you about reprogramming
some of that giving you some some
information about Zeno free workflows
that we can help support you with and
we've talked about during the class
keeping the QC analysis of your pscs
through into differentiation however
once you differentiate into whatever it
is that you're that you're looking at
what are some safety assays that you
might want to consider before putting it
back into the patient and so these will
be questions that you should consider
upfront before you go in your
preclinical clinical work and and we we
have some things to help support you
with that so there's been recent
concerns of CSU's harboring p53 mutation
and not posing a safety risk so a
substantial fraction of pscs around 6%
harbor p53 mutations there's 15
instances of p53 mutations that have
been observed when a researcher with h9
es es from different labs so the same
cell line in four different labs
harbored these mutations and so careful
genetic characterization of your
pluripotent stem cells should be carried
out before clinical use and one of the
ways that we can help support you with
this as we have an on combine a say this
is multiple biomarker and
next-generation sequencing this assay
has been adopted by leading cancer
institutions or in the world and is used
to profile thousands of samples and
different translational and clinical
research products including including
the NCI match trial this delivers
consistent and reliable results so as
you can see here we have a number of
hotspot genes full-length genes copy
number genes and gene fusions that are
evaluated in this uncle mine assay so
this is something that a lot of we get a
lot of questions about for the p53
mutation risk and we do have something
to help you with that evaluation when
you're ready for that step
so we we wanted to utilize this and show
that the cells that we reprogrammed they
don't have the hotspot variants so the
number of variants between the parental
fibroblasts and PSP clones were
comparable so as you can see on the left
we have the first line is the parental
fiberglass used in the
the workflow here as well as a number of
subclones that we derived from that we
also have h 9e SP line b g o1 v EFC line
and then some positive control a
positive control so although some splice
variants reserved none of them harbored
any cancer hotspot variants so the p53
variant remains same across parental and
IP SCS
all IPS use derived from the cts site
attune IPS c kit to point 1 lakh the
hotspot variants in our hence safe so
this assay helped us detect any risk of
introducing cancer back into the patient
so the last thing you want to do when
you're treating in disease is introduce
another disease or another risk so this
is a really great way to help you make
sure that you're not going to introduce
that into the patient
another key safety measure is making
sure that the IPS be clones that you
derive are actually from the same fiber
blast parental cells that you took from
the patient so there have been a number
of papers that have shown that cell
lines have been misclassified or
misidentified and that they can be mixed
up so in order to have another safety
measure and this will be something that
will be important as you move into GMP
is to make sure that you know what you
took from the patient what you grew in
the lab and what you put back in the
patient are from the same patient so
it's not very practical to just have one
patient in the lab so we know that
there's going to be some risk and so
what can we do to help you with that and
we have something called the identify or
direct kit and this helps you do
fragment fragment analysis and map the
software to show that these are the same
cells that you took from the patient
before so and in this example we use the
identify alert PCR amplification kit to
confirm that the IPS be clones match
with the parental fibroblasts
so at the top we have just a research
youth only Gimpo PSC so we we help
support labs by providing clear potent
stem cells
for some other research youth as a
positive control we also have the h9
ICSP
that are available and we've compared
those and then we took the fibre black
with two of our phones and showed that
those are indeed from the same fiber
blast donor so as you can see on the
right obviously our r2 controls did not
match thankfully and did not have any
contamination in our clone and then we
show that our fiber glass and our our
clones are from the same individual so
this assay using the applied Biosystems
identify their PCR amplification kit
it's critical to determine that cell
identity and distinguish it from other
products being manufactured in the same
facility this helps you ensure there's
no selling mix-up or contamination when
you're looking at when you're making
these PSC clones so here's the here's
the price that's really important for
you that I've been hinting at throughout
the entire presentation let's let's talk
about the cell therapy system and and
what that means
so give Cho CTS means cell therapy
systems products provide you with a
proven choice so you can transition
yourself therapy work so we have 20
years of GMP manufacturing of cell
therapy products and we also have
extensive documentation to help support
you so if you buy a CTS branded product
what does that mean for you first of all
it's manufactured in a cgmp compliant
manufacturing facility and what's really
going to be important for you as you're
thinking towards salt therapy and
treatment of patients and clinical
trials is to make sure that the reagents
and the ramas ancillary materials that
you're utilizing are are compliant with
the 21 CFR part 820 so these are
manufactured in cGMP that's for medical
devices our facility has utilized for
medical device manufacturing and this
for the 21 CFR part 820 so this F G a
registered manufacturing site we also
have ISO 13485 certified quality systems
and the ability to support you with all
the documentation you need so what does
it mean to have that 21 CFR part 820 so
first of all the cell therapy system
they're registered so that you can use
them in cell and gene therapy
manufacturing what that comes with as
support for you as you're working on
your preclinical work to file your IND
as we give you traceability
documentation including drug master file
so we have already sent a lot of
information to the FDA for you so that
when it goes when it's time for you to
file you to say reference this drug
master file and that eliminates the need
for you to do extra paperwork so we're
helping you with the paperwork when it
comes to filing with the FDA it also
means that there's extensive safety
testing so this includes sterility
endotoxin adventitious agents and
mycoplasma on applicable products so
that just means we're giving you the
safest best reagents and ancillary
materials to help you with your cell
therapy use in addition to that our CTS
products have been used in a number of
commercial products out on the market so
they're used in fda-approved cardkey
cell therapies and they've also been
used in the first fda-approved
therapeutic cancer vaccine additionally
where the our products are used in over
100 clinical trials so that gives you
that reassurance and confidence that
when you're using one of our cell
therapy system cts branded products that
it really means that you're working with
something that's safe and that you can
rely on when you're when you're going to
work with patients and go to the clinic
we have some references on this page to
of some of those some of those things
that I've been talking about as far as
the FDA approved car T cell therapies
with some press releases about about
that
um and then so I talked to you about
I've talked to you about reprogramming
I've hinted a little bit at the media
system so we have a really nice webinar
that Joanna gave a couple weeks ago
which I recommend you listening to where
she really does a deep dive into the pts
essential eight and the essential eight
products that you can utilize for this
it's really cool webinar as well so
we've talked about the media we talked
about the quality testing that you need
and we talked about some of the safety
tests that we recommend but you do we
have all of the CTF products compatible
for the entire workflow and my answer is
we have a number of CCS products that
are compatible that are compatible with
TTS essential 8 as well as use the
entire workflow so we have CTF knockout
serum replacement excess which is good
for helping you with your fibre black
culture we have the reprogramming kit
which I talked to you about that have
the growth matrices that I also talked
about we have bursting and CTS triple le
select and revita self so revita cell is
a good product for when you're sawing
yourself after banking them that really
helps you get the recovery that you'd
like to see and then banking in recovery
we have a number of products too we have
this into freeze we have
cryopreservation kit and like I was
mentioning the revital cell supplement
in addition to these workflow products
that we can help you with in your entire
workflow we also have the
characterization tools that I've talked
to you about so we have those cellular
based methods that I talked about with
the PSE live staining kit we have the
immuno Saito chemistry kits and the
three germ layer and we know that our
chemistry kit but as I talked to you
about in this entire side and I hope
I've conveyed to you the importance of
is looking at the characterization at
the molecular level if you want to be
sure that you're saving yourself time
and energy and making sure that you're
producing the products that are safe so
the ones that we talked about here where
the document HP SD score card the pleura
tests the prime view gene expression FA
and the kurios assays so we're able to
support you
that entire workflow with CTS products
so that really helps you so make sure
that you you talk with us or or the
others are more Fisher colleagues about
making sure that you have stuff when
you're using the research is only making
sure that you have something that's
compatible for when it's time to move to
the cell therapy system products for
your translational work a good time to
be doing that is early and your process
development but for sure preclinical
stages are a good time to do that
translational work to switch over to
that
CTS product because that helps save you
that time money and efficiency that we
talked about you're going to be
evaluating with the product that you
utilize all the way through and that'll
be really beneficial in saving you all
that a lot of time and effort and money
so I hope that we've been able to have
some sort of learning on what we can do
and help you with and your integrated
approach for the generation of high
quality IPSC solving when it comes to
translational use I talk to you about
the generation expansion of ipsps
quality testing and Bips d banks and the
safety testing that we recommend
performing before putting these cells
back into the patient for the cell
therapy that you've developed I want to
I want to really thank all the
researchers and people that are
listening in the audience today for your
work we're very passionate about
bringing cell therapy cell and gene
therapy forward and I'm excited to work
with you guys every day it's a really
cool field and so so thanks for paying
attention to the things that you need to
to help these these treatments get to
the clinic faster and with that I'd like
to thank you for your attention and open
it up for questions
thank you dr. hexam for your informative
presentation we will now start the live
Q&A portion of the webinar if you have a
question you'd like to ask please do so
now just click on the answer question
box located on the far left to your
screen it will answer as many of your
questions as we have time for so let's
get started
dr. hexam our first question is Carrie
at verse Carrie shd what do I use which
one
that's a great question so I think you
know I touched on it a little bit so for
the the low resolution and high
resolutions assays it's a matter of what
level of safety are you looking for are
you just doing a quick test before you
develop your process further for
differentiation then we recommend using
the low the low resolution kit however
if you're to the stage where you're
doing this clinical work and taking
samples from patients that might be
utilized or banked for potential
therapies in the future we highly
recommend using the HD so that you can
detect both the CMV and the SNP and so
you have real confidence in the
insertion or deletion I also get some
researchers who are interested in
genetically manipulating doing gene
editing of their PFC clones and
sometimes they want to they want to just
do one SNP deletion or addition and so
this is also appropriate at that time if
you do that gene editing to use the
resolution that you need for how how big
or little your your gene editing can be
so it really depends on your workflow
but overall the general if you're doing
research use only use the carry asset if
you're going to clinic and having real
patients and you want to make sure it's
safe to go back into the patient we
recommend that you evaluate and utilize
the kurios set HD but like I said if
you're doing genome editing and you need
that higher resolution it might also be
useful for that we do also provide the
carry offset serve service for you if
you don't want to do this in-house so
it's something that you can utilize and
send to us to to perform for you as well
with a good question now let's move on
to our next question
I've already derived myself in essential
8 now can I transfer them to CTS
essentially
yes for sure so we have a protocol and
suggestion for how to adapt that it's
fairly easy I did mention Joanna's
webinar which I recommend you listen to
and click on or else we have provided on
the website a really seamless workflow
for for trance transitioning yourselves
from EA to CTF e 8 so really that CGS e
8 what we did is we made sure that we
had we've done all the paperwork and
documentation and that would have good
good raw materials for that cell and
gene therapy so there isn't going to be
a lot of a lot of difference but it's
always good to do that that transfer in
that adaptation for you and so I
recommend utilizing those those tools
that we have available for you if you
have have that your cells already in the
e8
we are getting so many great questions
is but we do only have time for a couple
more so let's keep going now why would I
want to use both excuse me clear test
and scorecard
that's a great question so there you
know we get the question only because of
the pluripotency but as I hope that I
was able to show you they're
complementary
so the plur Express is really great when
it comes to standardization making sure
that you're comparable you have
reference sets and that you're doing
comparable work among the lat all the
labs in the world right so that's really
great for making sure you have the
pluripotency and and having
comparability and standardization in the
field now the scorecard is also great
because that shows you the
differentiation potential so you know
that that paper that I showed you
they're quite complementary and so
making sure that you can differentiate
into the three germ layers it's also
very important because if you have that
differentiation defect you're going to
have a lot of problems deriving the
cells that you want down the line so
they're they're complementary and
something that we recommend utilizing
together and you know hopefully you
don't just take my word for it you
utilize that publication and read over
that publication that I showed you in
this webinar today to help you make that
decision for yourself
dr. hexam it looks like we have time for
one more question can you identify
translocation with cario stud
oh I love that question so I did talk
about it a little bit right we talked
about it in the in the in the talk a
little bit but so I've had some some
researchers think that this replaces G
branding completely and like we
discussed a little bit when it comes to
a molecular based assay I can tell you
what the gene is there or not there or
whatever it is that the probe that
you're detecting but I cannot tell you
if it's moved so translocation cannot be
assessed however you know as as you
continue in this world the number of
places that can perform G banding
there's a large backlog there's a lot of
pain points that we have for that in the
field so we recommend that you use the
Carrio stat and then the next best thing
is to try NGS but a lot of people can't
afford NGS and so this is a really good
in-between product for helping you with
that so no it cannot detect
translocation based on the on the the
type of assay it is it's a molecular
assay so it cannot show that however
sometimes like I mentioned with those
with those translocations you might have
deletions in the in the genes and so you
want it you want to utilize something
like Carrio set so hey you might use G
banding to show that you don't have
translocations early on and then B what
you would do to be complimentary is to
if you do find a translocation and you
feel comfortable that it doesn't have a
functional risk you might want to end
analyze the the genes that are being
deleted in addition to it so there they
don't one doesn't necessarily replace
the other but one has a less of a pain
point for you and inability to show a
deeper resolution so now it cannot
detect translocation but it can help you
look at the deletion of the genes around
that translocation that usually occur
and get a lot better resolution into
what what's happening at the molecular
level
to hexam do you have any final comments
for our audience
no I just I just really appreciate the
fact that I was able to give this
webinar today I love talking to the
scientists that are working in the field
it's it's so exciting it's really
personal to me and all of my colleagues
at thermo Fisher to help you guys make
the world cleaner healthier and safer
healthier in this regard
you know as a previous neuroscientist
and somebody who works in the cell
therapy field I loved seeing what's
coming out and I really just encourage
you to interact with us and develop the
relationship so that we can continue to
have these important and interesting
conversations about moving the field
forward thank you so much for the work
that you guys are doing most of you who
are listening and we look forward to
working with you in the future so thanks
a lot thank you again dr. hexam for your
time today and your important research
we would also like to thank laberd's and
our sponsor Thermo Fisher Scientific for
underwriting today's educational webcast
before we go I'd like to thank the
audience for joining us today
and for their interesting questions
questions we didn't have time for today
and those submitted during the on-demand
period will be addressed by the speaker
via the correct information that you
provided at the time of registration
this webcast can be viewed on demand for
june of 2019 lever to alert you via
email when it's available for replay and
we encourage you to share that email
with your colleagues for business
today's live event until next time
goodbye